hey
Johnny how bad is school going to suck
you're not going to like it how bad it's
like getting your nuts smashed together
so hard they become just one nut holy
[__] you should be going to school every
day with John no thanks you might have
fun no I would not have fun I gu the
house when you guys are
[Music]
out what happened to the TV it was an
accident you're going to school and
you're going to grow a [__] brain oh
come on if I did
I know I'm going hey D you bringing your
dolls to school it's the '90s times are
changing sexual education let's start
with masturbation if you're going to
assign homework Johnny already did it
this morning you shut the [__] up
dude I haven't smoked I haven't had sex
I haven't had a girlfriend I'm going to
lose it you and me have been best
friends like our whole lives we're about
to get high for the first time can we
have drugs please let's do this
right
oh
man can you guys believe we're like
having an experience and experienc in
reality is there a [__] gas leak or
something nice costume F face it's
possible that the two of you might not
be total
screw-ups take a long look this is what
life is holy [__] Teddy I'm the last
virgin in school we can fix this got to
find a fire fresh penis get your fresh
penis herey Jesus Christ still has that
new penis smell you shut up all right
I'm just trying to
[Music]
help